اذا كان الجميع يريد انهاء حاله الانسداد
هذه ويريد
الفعلا عقد انتخابات تعبر عن الشعب الليبي
ما الذي يعرقلها حتى الان لماذا تتوقف
لماذا لا نسير الى الامام في موضوع
الانتخابات
موضوع مهم وانا اسمحي لي يعني اتحدث معك
بالتفصيل في هذه المساله اولا الانتخابات
بقدر ما هي غايه لكن في نفس الوقت هذه
الانتخابات تحتاج الى تحيه وتحتاج الى عمل
وتحتاج الى اداره يعني الان احنا للاسف في
ليبيا نتج عندنا موجود ادارتين يعني اداره
بيسمى بالحكومه الوطنيه
وهي الان من خلال البرلمان
طار من هناك ادارتين لن نتمكن من انجاز
هذه الانتخابات اذا الخطوه الاولى انه
لازم تكون في اداره واحده زي ما عامل
المجتمع الدولي وعقد لقاءات في تونس وفي
جنيف نتج عنها هذه الحكومه اللي هي تسمى
الحكومه الوطنيه يجب ان نحن الان نفكره في
مخرج برعايه اماميه برعايه دوليه برعايه
وطنيه هذا ينتج عنها اداره واحده بحيث هذه
الاداره تتمكن من القيام بالانتخابات
هذه الخطوه الاولى اذن يجب ان احنا ليه
بيكون فيها اداره وحده لاداره المشهد
التنفيذي وصولا الى الانتخابات النقطه
الثانيه
وممكن حضرتك تصريحات
النائب العام الليبي في هناك مشاكل حقيقيه
حدثت يعني مثلا هناك تزوير فيما يسمى
بالرقم الوطني هذا التصوير تصوير وصل
لحوالي 90000 مواطن دخلوا
وسجلوا باحتباره الليبيين وهم مشرفين
السجل المدني بتصريح النائب العام في اكثر
من 65 شخص
65,000 شخص همم وجد انه موجود جوازات
مزوره اكثر من 20 الف جواز
اذن في هذه الحاله علينا لما تكون في
اداره اداره واعيه واداره وطنيه اول خطوه
الديرها تعمل مراجعه لهذه السجلات تعمل
تدقيق حتى سجل الناخبين استاذ منتهي همم
النائب العام يتحدث عن
25000 بطاقه مزوره معناها هناك مشكله بس
لو كان في السجل والله في همم ارقام
الوطنيه والله في السفر معطيه ناس جاوبيين
هم مش كبير او في همم البطاقات الانتخابيه
اول خطوه نعملوها نعمله مراجعه وتدقيق
والتاكدوا ان هذه الارقام صحيحه الشيخ
الثاني المهم استاذ منتهى في هذا الامر
همم موضوع السلاح يعني السلاح خارج
المؤسسه
الرسميه القانونيه اللي هي القوات المسلحه
والامن اللي هو الشرطه اي سلاح وهذا ما
اعتقد انه مغطى حتى بالقرارات الدوليه
1970 او 1973 ان كل سلاح يجب يكون تحت
المؤسسات الوطنيه وان الامم المتحده يجب
ان تشرب
وتكتمل هذه الصوره بحيث ان يكون السلاح
تحت
المؤسسات الرسميه
انت عندك سلاح وانا ما عندي سلاح ونحن
ونعملوا العمليه العمليه الانتخابيه لما
بكره ان شاء الله تطلع انت خاسر وانا ناجح